hey everybody welcome to my talk on
campus performance tips you will learn
how to pixels well as Adam mentioned my
name is Angelina if you are interested
in complaining about code sometimes
retweeted articles about code a curated
selection of red panda gifts or perhaps
you're just interested in the slides
from this talk afterwards you can follow
me as Angelina Magnum on Twitter so
whenever I start writing code on the
Internet
which is basically all that we do
invariably when I'm learning something
new I come across this idea you know
that you should just write code worried
about performance later and in essence
this is actually mostly true you don't
want to try and over optimize too early
otherwise you're spending a lot of time
tweaking things which may not have a
larger impact on the project you're
working on but more importantly in my
opinion you'll get distracted from all
the code that you should be writing to
get the project done so the person that
wrote this or that writes quote quotes
like this on the internet and you often
find this attached to performance
related articles I think is mostly
correct but I don't think entirely I
think we should think about this just a
little bit differently so I like to say
now as of yesterday optimizations are a
last step best practices should be every
step so I'm hoping today that I give you
some ideas about best practices working
with canvas that are easy for people
that are both new to canvas and maybe
seasoned people I hope that I teach you
one or two things that you you didn't
already know so first of all let's
travel back in time to the 1990s so once
upon a time in the 1990s
we had some limitations in our browser
right there wasn't a lot we could do
with a drawing we had HTML which you
know before the word web application was
even a thing we could create you know
documents that were just mostly like
documents we got introduced to CSS which
provided some styling for said documents
and it actually took quite a while till
we could do sophisticated drawing these
days in 2014 you can do really
sophisticated CSS transforms and
animations and there's like if you ever
go over onto a code pen there's some
really fantastic examples of the stuff
that people are doing there
so when early programmers of the 1990s
came up against the limitations of the
browser and thought like well I want to
make a I want to make a game and keep in
mind javascript wasn't cool yet it was
still you know like a new kid on the
block
and when people were met up against the
boundary of the browser they sought to
extend the browser using plugins so a
couple of the early things that we had
for drawing the web was VRML or ver
Mille which was a standardized markup
language for describing objects in 3d
space and applying textures to them and
that kind of was a thing but then it
really wasn't it was superseded by
something called X 3d and then it was
superseded by like everything else and
then there were these things Java
applets this one still exists you can
play it on the internet and you should
check it out because it's really a blast
from the past
although the Java like the latest Java
Runtime for the browser will warn you
that there's like tons of security
exceptions I can leave out that this
didn't install viruses on my computer so
if you do feel like going into the past
at your own risk so at least there's at
least two and I mean there's there's
more than just the three I'm going to
talk about but of course there's also
Macromedia Flash which eventually went
on to become and Dobey product and flash
is still around
I don't know for how long and that's for
good reason because we have some better
methods for drawing in the browser we
have AP eyes in the browser for doing
drawing and creating animations so we've
got this canvas tag which is basically
all you need for drawing but then
there's also this SVG thing too so when
do you use SVG and when to use canvas
we'll explore that in just a little bit
first of all let's take a look at a
simple animation with canvas and I've
got like a little code pen up here that
I whipped up you can see on the
t'ayn said I guess that's a little bit
small and see if I can zoom in and not
have this be terrible it's kind of okay
collapse of pain alright so we've got
just a canvas element there and over on
the right hand side I'm grabbing the
canvas element throw it into a variable
set some other variables like width and
height so don't have to recalculate
those times that recalculate those every
time I need them and then there's this
thing called the context as I call I use
canvas like get context I tell it using
this string that I would like a 2d
context as opposed to a WebGL context
which we will get to and if you're
unfamiliar with canvas you can think of
a context kind of like a toolbox in a
sense much like a traditional artist
that's drawing on a canvas you will have
a toolbox that's filled with things like
paints and colors you know you know
brushes that can draw lines of various
widths and so I find that for people who
are beginners the best metaphor that
I've found and this is thanks to a
friend of mine is actually that you
should think of the context kind of like
a toolbox we're not just doing simple
drawing here right this is actually a
really fabulous animating Red Square
it's basically the best animating Red
Square and what we're doing here is
we've got this function called draw
where we call requestanimationframe and
then we call draw there and although
that does look like recursion what we're
doing the first time we call it is we're
actually basically saying in the browser
please the next time you have a frame
for animating give it to me and then do
all this stuff and then we're telling
our context that we're kind of like
dipping our brush in this bright blue
color and then drawing from the origin
of zero zero on the top left we did we
draw and paint the whole canvas blue and
then we hold on to that we save it and
then we actually translate our origin
points for where we're drawing from and
then we rotate and we do the same thing
again we dip our brush in this really
bright red color and we do a fill rect
which is painting a rectangle and then
we restore it and bam you've got this
animation so I mean we did that and you
know I mean there's a lot of comments in
here but less than less than 50 lines
with really verbose comments for for you
know beginners so that's you know kind
of okay oh wait that's a terminal you
don't want that where's my talk all
right so that's pretty simple the
interesting corollary here is that
there's a simple loop that's updating
the canvas and one of the things I've
noticed is that if people do not have a
computer science graphics background
or they've never messed around with
canvas and some of you some people just
actually never thought like well how
does the video game work and actually
video game works in the simplest sense
of by updating the screen in a loop and
then you add you know gameplay and game
state to that and that's how a game is
made so if you've ever wondered like how
are your video video games are made even
at you know the highest level of Triple
A games this is essentially a core part
of how games work so we did that with
canvas now let's take a look at this
thing called WebGL and let's try it
lecture what we're going to do is we're
going to take a look an example that
draws and animates the exact same square
okay so over on the nope that's not the
one okay over on the left hand side here
we have see we've got canvas okay but
there's some other stuff here we've got
this thing that's called in some script
tag here on its own a GL frag color and
that doesn't look like something I've
seen in JavaScript then we've got this
other thing GL position never seen that
before and over on the right hand side
here yeah we it's pretty short right oh
this is all the draw one animating
square oh no I'm not done yet look keeps
going whoo okay okay so there's this
WebGL thing it's considerably more of a
boasts in the canvas API that's an
observation we can make so far and WebGL
for the uninitiated I assume that most
people probably heard about WebGL and
passing at least it's using basically
the OpenGL language on the web's like
almost like a port of that to basically
get closer to the metal push off a bunch
of calculations and graphics work onto
the GPU and so it has significant
advantages over just the 2d canvas API
which I introduced we're going to talk a
little bit more about that so yeah that
was a simple animation with WebGL and
honestly that thing was so long that I
mean I we just can't even really go
through all of it that didn't scale well
but you get the point I love this guy
looks so much alright so if you're not
coming from an OpenGL background like
and you want to use WebGL you basically
got to learn a new language and you've
got to be introduced these things called
shaders which are kind of an important
concept you can't really get around that
either so shaders simplified almost too
much and anybody who's a pro and hearing
me say the
stuff is gonna be like but but not but
not actually but not all shaders and oh
no this didn't scale well I wonder if I
can refresh this give me a sec here
let's see yeah there we go
so shaders simplified almost too much
are basically individual programs that
run on the GPU and give your 3d drawings
life and what I mean by that very simply
we've got two kinds vertex rate vertex
shaders they transform position they run
once per vertex in a mesh before these
other things called fragment shaders and
a mesh you can think of as a bunch of
connected vertices fragment shaders run
once per pixel between vertices to
essentially paint your 3d objects you
can't make 3d stuff with WebGL with
without using shaders so I'm just
sitting here talking about canvas and
WebGL and then I mentioned this thing
called SVG scalable vector graphics and
you're probably wondering like how do I
know when to use which of those so let's
go through like some of the reasons you
might want to use one or the other so
scalable vector graphics are pretty
interesting so you want to use scalable
vector graphics when you want something
with a Dom like internal hierarchy SVG
has the ability to have these nodes that
behave very Dom like and they'll fire
events for you so if you're looking for
something with simple interactions a
Plus SVG is pretty cool you want to be
able to easily draw non square shapes
because that's vector based it does a
really really nice smooth curve so
that's pretty awesome
if you're scaling dimensions is
important then this is actually pretty
fantastic again being vector based we'll
talk about what to do to properly scale
a canvas if you need to and still keep
things performant but if possible just
don't resize your canvas depending on
implementation and stuff the
interpolation can make it look really
goofy if you don't need if you don't
need a billion nodes because depending
again on SVG implementation having lots
and lots of nodes in SVG can degrade
performance I did talk to some people
and someone on platform mentioned that
it really does vary by implementation in
fact there's some stuff that seems to be
for some SVG implementations that could
be pushed onto the GPU but isn't it's on
the CPU and rendering like lots of
curves and gets to be a pain so
no to you speedy judicious if you want
to display a mostly static chart or
create a simple point-and-click game
simple user interactions with really
smooth nice graphics that you want to
scale well that's when you want to use
SVG so a cool idea is rather using SVG
for game you could build like a games
level editor using SVG and that's
probably a pretty good use so when do
you want to use canvas and we mean the
2d canvas API the very first example
that we use so maybe you don't want an
internal structure a Dom like structure
handling events for you you want control
over which pixels exactly fire events so
you can have ultimate precision by
controlling each individual pixel
probably you want something maybe retro
fabulous because 8-bit style art it
turns out kind of hard to do with canvas
but doing or probably kind of hard to do
with SVG but much easier to do with
canvas so recommend if you that's the
style you're going forward that you're
going to want to use canvas and if you
want to make a fast paced game not just
a point-and-click something that's a
shoot-'em-up FPS or if you want to
display real time visualizations and
charts canvas is going to be your friend
now WebGL this magic thing I was telling
you about they can offload stuff onto
the GPU gets you better performance when
performance is the most important thing
you want to you want to use WebGL and in
fact you can still draw with you know
WebGL in 2d which was the example I
showed you obviously the most popular
thing to do is draw on 3d with it but if
you drew on 2d with WebGL and you deal
with all that for both Ness you can
actually get much more performant 2d
animations 2d games than just drawing
with the canvas API so that's something
to consider if you know performance is
an issue and if you want to draw loss of
3d shapes I'm comparing this here
actually as well to a lot of three 3d
CSS transforms animations not because
like one or two of those aren't terribly
performant in fact our browsers are
pretty fast these days right but if you
have lots and lots and lots of 3d shapes
and lots and lots and lots of layers and
transparency and effects and you've got
tons of dom nodes well things are going
to actually slow down quite a bit so I
would recommend using WebGL instead of
doing that although I think the 3d CSS
stuff we can do now is pretty wicked so
often you know you think like you saw
that you saw this like in Angelina
like an example of WebGL and I showed
you how to simply draw so it's basically
simple now that you know one or two
things about WebGL you can basically
that's it you know just there you go
that was how to draw square now go make
a game right so it's not that simple but
there are lots of really excellent
tutorials on the internet that will that
will help you out with that so I just
wanted to make sure people sort of knew
the appropriate uses of canvas SVG WebGL
before we actually get onto the meat of
everything which is of course talking
about canvas performance and WebGL
performance so you might say to yourself
but I want to write JavaScript I don't
want to learn a new language I mean
those shades were cool but I don't
really want to be writing shaders
explicitly that was just like a lot of
code just to make us square I mean oh my
gosh
but there are some libraries that will
help you the most popular one and of
course that a lot of you might be
familiar with is three J's which
abstract way working with 3d and web
with WebGL tween jeaious is an excellent
library for basically animating between
smoothly and then I found this other one
that I think is really really excellent
for if you're doing 2d rendering it's
called pix ejs and it's a it's like I
said a 2d WebGL render but they're all
some thing is it has a canvas fallback
if you can't shove stuff onto the GPU so
that's really nice if you're doing 2d
games and you're going cross-platform
right so when you're using a library if
it's written by somebody else and it's
not something that has you know a lot of
community support you know maybe it's
like a new game framework or something
that you found you're kind of like well
the screenshots look really cool and the
demos are really cool maybe I'll use
this you know something like 3GS is I
guess a little bit battle-hardened
because there are a lot of people that
work on it my friend Sola is here she's
actually the author of tween J's we were
talking about three J's last night
really yeah there's this guy in Slovenia
who's amazing he spends like hours
optimizing all the shaders and in every
browser so to that guy hats off to you
so he's done a lot of the hard work for
you making sure that the you know your
CPU and GPU are not doing extra work
however imagine a situation where you
have you know a set of functions
someone's created like a nice API to
abstract away some of this work for you
and you have a phone you call a canvas
like clear the canvas yourself and then
maybe you call a function that you know
is opaque to you because you haven't
looked at the source code and
called prepare canvas so intuitive you
might be like okay first I'm gonna clear
the canvas and then I'm gonna prepare it
and then I do some work sure that sounds
intuitive to me but what happens you
know if prepare canvas also calls a
clear canvas then you're doing what's
called redundant draw calls so and
that's just doing work twice like come
on we don't want to do that so let's
actually take a look at that one good
way to inspect this is using the canvas
inspector in Firefox which we landed I
think just a couple months ago we
actually announced it at GDC and
actually um use the shader editor to
which will actually pull up WebGL
shaders I'll show you in a moment
because if you are somebody who is a
little bit curious abut under the hood
you can actually live edit those shaders
in the browser and see them update in
real time it's an excellent learning to
like when I was diving into this stuff I
was like oh okay this isn't so bad
having that immediate feedback is really
great kind of like using a ripple
alright so let's go through this step by
step frame by frame so this is an
example here of inefficient canvas usage
actually and it's a very simple example
so it's deceptive but will actually take
a look here with the canvas inspector
let me see if I can make this bigger so
that's kind of getting bigger maybe a
bit bigger okay we'll see how it will
see how the inspector responds to that
let's scroll up here a bit and I got to
reload the page click on this to record
animation frames call stack okay so what
we have here is basically the canvas
inspector when you grab a snapshot of it
will show you basically all the draw
calls that are going to be executed in
order to implement like the next step of
animation so I mean this is a really
simple one so at the bottom we've
rolling about these like three frames
right here for more sophisticated stuff
like if you go to the WebGL playground
and take a look at some of the examples
there and that's like on Heroku I
believe then you can actually you know
run some of these in the canvas
inspector you can go into the shade or
editor and play with them and then
really see what's going on under the
hood and the canvas are supporting the
WebGL playground on heroic is actually
pretty good because it's got like the
live code that you can edit in the page
anyway but this is really good for
seeing performance so if we look
actually at the code here is my bad cams
example I've got this all stuffed in the
head don't actually do this we've got
here C requestanimationframe looks kind
of similar
to our example when we're animating
there you can see that we're doing a
fill style right here and a fill rekts
and then we're calling this function I
was kind of using this example of
prepare frame if we go over into the
canvas inspector you'll see that we've
got some duplicated calls your fill rect
is being called twice and stroke style
is being called twice there's no reason
to duplicate effort if we go back into
our code and we take a look and we'll
see that when we're calling prepare
frame there we go that fill rect is
called and drawcircle also sets a stroke
style as well so this is a really
obvious example of duplicated draw calls
and from inspecting a couple games over
the last while I recognized that there
are often cases where things look like
repeat draw calls but sometimes there is
like some meaning towards you know
behind the scenes that's not obvious to
why that might be there but when you do
see those in you know the canvas
inspector it's a pretty good indication
that you might want to take a look at
that in your code or look at the library
that's you picked up and didn't really
vet very hard on the internet and
because reducing the number of these
redundant draw calls can actually make a
difference
now this example isn't using shaders I
do have that WebGL example again the one
that we were using the code pens if we
inspect that and we pop over to oh I
don't have the shader editor so let's
turn that on if you're all looking for
the canvas in spectrum the shader editor
just got to click on like the sprocket
II thing the Firefox dev tools and
enable the shader editor there we go
awesome reload the page and so what's
going on here is when we were taking a
look in that code pen earlier we had
some script tags at how these things
called you know GL position and GL frag
and these things of course are our
vertex shaders and our fragment shaders
so actually what we can do is we can
actually go in here and we can modify
some of the stuff and what happens if I
show you just do it - that's not gonna
do anything there we go yeah pink square
so you can see that that updates in real
time for you which makes debugging and
learning I think this stuff a whole lot
better let's get those out of the way
keep on going step by step frame by
frame everybody so now let's dive right
into those performance best practices
that people are you know here for the
first thing is you want to make sure use
whole pixel rendering and what that
means is when you're specifying
you know like a draw operation don't use
floats if you don't have to if for some
reason your calculating something
dynamically and you get a float call
math dot floor or use bitwise operations
on it in order to make nice round
numbers because the cpu ends up having
to do a whole bunch of extra calculators
to ramp calculations to round them
anyway to give you a nice anti-aliasing
effect so just try and stay away from
that where possible cache your drawing
in an off-screen canvas image copying is
actually cheaper than redrawing pixels
so what you can do is something kind of
like this just create a canvas don't add
it to the DOM and then render some stuff
there and then render it onto the canvas
and that actually is a really great way
to to deal with deals performance so if
you're doing something has multiple
layers maybe you're doing kind of like a
parallax background if you've ever seen
like if you ever pulled apart old like
Super Nintendo games and stuff and seen
all the layers that go into the and into
that use kind of the same principle use
like sort of transparency and move the
layers a little bit and you can you can
that's actually a lot better than using
just one canvas because often you know
you're just using part of each canvas to
create a whole scene and you're drawing
just little portions of the candidates
rather than one big thing all over and
over again that being said only draw
what you have to there there's some
tutorials out there that I recommend you
poke around and find that will show you
how to only draw what you have to that
is to say don't redraw the entire canvas
only draw pixels that have changed like
basically though you can see the
recurring theme here's don't do any more
work than you absolutely have to if you
have a large unchanging background
behind your game like it literally is a
static thing then just apply it using
CSS don't draw it in canvas there's just
no reason to do that so that's a pretty
simple one I'm confident that most of
you I hope know how to use CSS you guys
are JavaScript developers so yeah but
and yeah large unchanging background
apply with CSS and here's just an
example of using multiple layers
actually with multiple canvases which
totally should have been with the
previous example but haha and then so
this is actually mostly applicable to
charts or maybe a game where you're
dealing with real time data so latency
is a thing right that's kind of a
problem I've seen people do real-time
charts and like the data will kind of
come in and it stutters and I know
immediately that they're not using a
queue
to deal with that so what you want to do
- you know animate smoothly and you know
avoid these latency issues as don't just
animate stuff when it comes in when you
get your data put it in a queue and then
it's some regular interval that you've
determined you know mitigate some of
your latency effects then then pull that
and pull off the next bit of data
animate that onto your off-screen canvas
and then when ready animate that onto
your your your canvas that your user can
see if you scale the canvas that all use
a css3 transform because those are GPU
accelerated when done right and that's
what we're looking for here so that's
pretty fantastic
and here's just an example right here of
doing that so you can actually do that
in JavaScript or you can apply it using
CSS and maybe it'll just scale Boop to
the viewport that you're looking for I
figure this stuff is actually pretty
simple for you so don't write your own
matrix operations library there's a
bunch of libraries out there that have
been already written and already
obsessed over for those optimizations
and at some point you might be like well
I don't know I don't like the API
surface of this library so I'm just
gonna write my own just don't like just
just don't because honestly it takes a
lot of time and debugging to get right
and unless you're somebody with the with
extensive background you're probably
going to mess it up get some of the
calculations
you know use an algorithm that's not
super optimized and impact your own
performance because you were you know
ambitious I mean that being said maybe
don't ship it in production for like
something you want and users to use and
make it a side project you can be
ambitious and write your own matrix
operation library but okay lots of peer
feedback on that sort of stuff and just
mostly don't do it so here's some other
stuff that affects performance that
might that's not necessarily directly a
canvas thing but definitely causes
problems avoid frequent calls to local
storage every time you do that it can
actually be a performance hit so do
those at particular intervals like for
example if you've got a game with levels
do that it like the score screen in
between levels if it's a game that
involves like a lot of real time stuff
and you want to somehow save state so
that like if you user gets disconnected
they can reconnect you know do that in
between turns somehow just find an
appropriate time to do it when things
like aren't animating and you're not
doing like a major draw or update
basically so just choose where
or you or when and where you call to
store things to local storage carefully
so really when you're when you're
creating something and doing stuff with
canvas
don't just keep creating new objects
willy-nilly reuse them from a pool
because if you don't if you don't you're
gonna get a graph in the chrome timeline
that looks something like this so a few
of you might know of course what's
what's going on here it's so like uh-oh
and it kind of drops off and this is a
game I found actually there's a really
simple person of course they're really
popular 2048 which by the way you guys
should check out threes I think it's a
way cooler implementation but somebody
here has gone and implemented a 3d
version of it and it's pretty simple
right like I started playing this was
like oh yeah this is really fun animated
nicely but the first time I started
playing it I mean my macbook air can
actually handle some pretty decent games
on steam without chugging and heating up
this game it looks really simple it was
like oh my god what are you doing to me
and it like got really really warm and
so I mean looking in the code was
actually if the code is actually not all
that straightforward it's it's up on
github and you know there's a couple
things that look like we're done and
draw calls but they were in three.js so
I'm not going to kind of trust the three
J's people but you know looking at this
timeline in in chrome you see this and
what's happening there is when it looked
in the code this person is actually
creating new tween objects all the time
rather than reusing them so it's like a
new object new object no garbage
collection and garbage collection is a
performance hit so please reuse objects
from an object pool you want to keep the
garbage collector board I know it's that
awesome feature to have but keep it as
bored as possible and so this here is
like the biggest wall of text you're
going to get in the presentation but
it's a simple example and of course I'll
give it the slides afterwards because
this is a little bit longer but you want
to basically initialize a pool of Woking
common objects and then you know pull
out an object use it for something put
it back in the pool and then you know
initialize it for something else and
that actually will be a lot better
because you're not doing a whole bunch
of garbage collection at these various
intervals that will then make your
animation and your game stutter if I
keep going with that 2048 game and we
start
getting more and more cubes and I just
keep going and flipping it around it
will start to stutter another another
tool to use as an FPS counter you can
actually find stats j/s which I believe
is I think I was talking to John John
David Dalton yesterday he made that and
then like now it's kind of in three J s
or mr. doob uses it so there's like a
little like JavaScript implementation
Chrome if you go into the dev tools
press escape while you're in there
you'll see a little rendering tab and
they have an FPS tool as well that's
that's really cool it actually it's
really badass it makes me feel like I'm
in the future it's like red and black
moving lines and then Firefox has got a
really nice integrated FPS widget that's
going to be shipping with our profiler
once we ship our brand-new profiler so
that's a thing so you know another part
about basically as another good metric
is to like you know look at your game
and see when your frame rate really
fluctuates or when it just like drops
down to ten like if I keep going in this
2048 game
I've got limited time so I'm not going
to pull it up but trust me if you just
find this game it's if you look for
cubics 2048 you'll find it and just run
an FPS counters you keep doing this and
you'll watch it go pew all the way down
so very fun game to play regardless
though so I'm some miscellaneous micro
optimizations remember I said like these
up until now these are mostly best
practices for doing your canvas stuff if
you get to the end and you really do
want to try and get a little bit more
bang for your buck out of performance
these are a few tips that I picked up
from really great articles on Mozilla
hacks talking to my friends who are from
like higher level wizards than I am at
canvas and there's also some good stuff
on html5 rocks as well from people at
Google use bitwise operators instead of
math dot floor a little bit more
performant clear arrays with length zero
to avoid creating a new array use
if-else over switch and actually I have
an article that I I can link to when I
send these out that has J s perfs for
for these use date now over new date a
voyage shadow blur you can do that to a
praia playa FEX two primitives but that
can actually be a performance hit as
well so oh my god this is so much stuff
right so everybody's like either really
quiet cuz they're like oh my god I'm in
are holy I'm totally confused but
that's good hopefully whatever I've said
you today makes you think like hmm
and now I've got like this handy bag of
tricks for working with canvas I don't
need to be afraid about going out there
and experimenting because you've got
like these ideas you can keep in the
back of your mind so that your canvas
stuff ends up being really fun for your
plans to favorite part of me ends up
being really fun for your friends to
play with on probably most devices in
fact a lot of these tips came from
tactics that people use for shipping
games on Firefox OS which the phones
that were shipping are you know they're
not your iPhone 5 and that's on purpose
actually they have much less power much
less memory than the fancy phones that
probably you or I have the ideas that
we're shipping these to emerging and
developing markets and pricing them
competitively so that people that would
buy a future phone will instead maybe be
introduced to smartphones and spend more
time on the web and stuff like that but
actually a really great metric is
Firefox list phones are super cheap you
can buy own for under 100 bucks if your
game runs really well on one of these
like less powerful like memory
constrained phones you can be pretty
confident it's gonna run really well in
other devices actually because you're
only ever as best as your worst
performing case in my opinion so that's
basically it I hope you enjoyed this
like slideshow